vsauce kevin here this ant needs to get
to the end of this
20 centimeter rubber rope it's really
more of an elastic
latex string but work with me here
if he moves five centimeters per second
he'll get there in one two
three four seconds
okay uh no no paradox there but
what if as the ant walks five
centimeters per second
i stretch the rope 10 centimeters per
second
will he ever get to the end of the rope
and fulfill his ultimate
ant ambitions and
ambitions it doesn't seem like it it
it actually seems completely impossible
how could he ever
reach the end of the rope if i'm
increasing the distance he needs to
travel by more than
his progress oh also
this ant's name is billy
speaking of ants i started reading about
them and found out that some ant queens
can live for 28
or 30 years which means there are
ants alive today that were 10 years old
when the first
harry potter came out
voice correct okay back to stretching
at zero seconds billy starts walking and
at one second
he's five centimeters towards his goal
that's when we stretch the rope another
10 centimeters and then billy moves
billy moves bill i can't stretch the
rope
and move billy at the same time i really
need like a
another arm or something like whoa hey
oh hey no no come back come back come
back
come back mystery arm uh i need your
help look
uh just hold this end of the rope
like that and then yeah
this is frightening but
helpful now after this stretch the rope
is 30 centimeters long
and look billy's no longer at five
centimeters because the key to
all of this is that the ant is on the
rope and he stretches
with the rope so to make sure he moves
exactly five centimeters each second
i'll just grab another ruler there we go
billy moves another five centimeters and
now we stretch to 40 centimeters
billy moves another five 50 centimeters
another five for billy 60 centimeters
five more for billy 70 centimeters and
you can see that despite
stretching the rope much more than the
ground he covers each second
billy is making progress toward the end
so a 5 centimeter speed and 10
centimeter stretch
really isn't much of a paradox here
either
but what if we stretch the rope one
kilometer and billy moves at only a
one centimeter per second pace and we
stretch it
one kilometer every second then can
billy ever reach the end
of the rope obviously not
or definitely yes and there's our
paradox
ant on a rubber rope is a veritable
paradox
which we learned about in my what is a
paradox video it's the type of paradox
that packs a surprise because
obviously the ant can't reach the end of
the rope if we stretch it that
much every second but that
certainty dissipates as we ponder the
proof
actually if i stretch it one kilometer
per second
and the ant only moves one centimeter
per second
he will still reach the end as long as
all
billy here lives forever okay let's
ponder that proof
it's important to think about this as
the fraction of the rope that billy has
left to travel
instead of the raw distance i'll show
you
let's put billy at the halfway mark of
the rope
like that and then i'm just gonna mark
where he's standing
with the sharpie on the rope okay
so that mark is our billy and this time
billy doesn't move at all he just
stands there being billy every time we
stretch the rope distance is added
behind
and in front of the rope but he's still
at the halfway point because
his relative position doesn't change
which means that in spite of the
stretching
every time billy steps forward from this
point
he's making progress toward reaching the
end of the rubber rope
by continuing his journey forward he can
only get
closer to the end and eventually
he will because he's always shrinking
the
fraction of the rope he has left
if you still don't believe this then we
can totally get
algebraic and calculus
first i want to briefly mention the
harmonic series
it's a divergent series meaning a
partial sums of the series
don't have a finite limit it was first
proven over 600 years ago and there's
been
a whole list of different proof synths
that i'll link you to
down in the description below but the
important thing to know is
that it's like a never ending addition
problem where the sum
of these fractions eventually surpasses
one okay let's talk about billy and his
stretching rope let's say the rope is
initially c units long and the ant
moves a units toward the other end of
the robe every second but the rope
itself
stretches v units longer every single
second
during the first second the ant will
have moved
a units forward and the rope will have
stretched
c plus v units long
cool cool in the second second the ant
will again
move a units forward and the rope
stretches another
v units longer making its new length its
original length
c plus v plus v again
which we could just write as c plus 2v
in the third second the ant will have
moved another a units forward
and the rope will be c plus v v v
units long or c plus 3
v during any second the fraction
of the rope the ant covers is just the
ratio between the two lengths
in that seconds row after the first
second the ant covers a units of the
total
c plus v units the rope is long during
the second second the ant covers a
units of the ropes now total c plus two
v
units of length and so on if you add
these two fractions you get the fraction
of the rope covered after the first
and second second the number of
fractions we
add corresponds to how many seconds have
elapsed
and their sum tells us the total
fraction of the rope
the ant has covered after that many
seconds one way to think about adding
fractions to represent a sum
is eating pizza okay take one
big bite of pizza and then a smaller
bite of pizza
add those two bites together and their
sum equals the total amount of pizza
you've just eaten so if we represent
seconds
as k during the k second
the ant covers one of the total c plus
k v units the rope is long okay
cool story kevin but the question is if
we wait
long enough if we add up enough of these
diminishing fractions of the rope's
length the ant covers during
each next second will the sum ever
equal one one whole of the rope's
length yes
and we could prove that by using a
comparison test
let's compare this series with one whose
behavior we know
the harmonic series we could do that by
creatively tweaking the general formula
for the fraction of the rope the ant
covers during any given second
k if we multiply not only v but
also c by k
then for any natural number k like
1 2 3 4 etc this
new formula will give us either the same
result as the original formula
well it'll give us the same result when
k equals one
because if k equals one then this is
just c and if k
equals one here that's just v so that
will be the same so that will be equal
or it'll give us a number that is
smaller
and this new formula a over kc plus kv
is equal to a over
c plus v times one
over k because one times a is just a
and then we still have the k times c and
k
times v okay got it and if we
generate a new series using this formula
when we start plugging in numbers for k
we get a over c plus v times one over
one
plus one over two plus one over three
plus
one over four and so on which is
the harmonic series
exciting so this new series we've
created diverges
as long as you keep adding in new values
for bigger
and bigger k's the sum can reach any
number you want including one
that's a big one and sim because this is
a big deal because since every element
of this new series is always
equal to or less than an element in the
series that describes the ant's progress
our ants progress must also diverge
so no matter how tiny the fractions get
no matter how long
it takes the ant to cover any proportion
of the rope
he will eventually cover one want of
whatever the rope's length has become
he will reach the end
but it'll take a long long time since a
smaller and smaller portion is covered
every step of the way
in our example of an ant traveling one
centimeter every second in a rope
stretching one kilometer longer every
second
the ant will reach the end after about
8.9
times 10 raised to the 43 421
years to put that number in perspective
the known universe is about 13.8 billion
years old
which is 1.38 times 10
to the 10. all the known atoms in the
observable universe
is about 10 raised to the 80 and a
googol is still
only 10 to the 100. so
what does a number with 43 400 421
zeros actually look like this
the real world analog to the ant on a
rubber rope would be light from distant
galaxies
traveling through space if photons are
traveling through a universe that is
constantly expanding will their light
ever
reach earth the ant on a rubber rope
teaches us that yes
yes the light will eventually reach us
or it would if the universe were
expanding at a constant
rate but the metric expansion of the
universe is
actually accelerating which means there
are ant
photons traveling through the universe's
rubber rope
that will never crawl into
your eyes so be sure to enjoy the
starlight that does make that journey
and as always
thanks for watching